someone should um you should check it
because it really smell like it smells
like he he pooped guys I just bought
this thing called liquid ass it's a
spray that smells like ass it's genius
so I'm gonna be pranking my friends with
it they think they're doing a video
about Amazon I'm actually testing our
friendship can I have a club Sarah okay
today we're gonna guess the price of
Amazon products today we are gonna guess
the price of Amazon products yeah I'm
gonna go to the bathroom over 15 minutes
stuffs Go Go Go yeah I've never used
Amazon before whoa really yeah no okay
that's the effect of Prime he has to go
to the bathroom I guess he's a toddler
that was pretty urgent I think give him
like five minutes and then if not then
then just recast
[Music]
it might be potty
it smells like he farted so I mean it
smells like like this straight
just but hey sorry about that
y'all good yeah no worries
everybody poops you guys smell it if
you're feeling okay to do we can do it
but if you're not I'm doing so like I'm
so embarrassed like I think I might use
my Anna smell you should I throw out the
underwear yes okay we go Throgmorton
still have them on
[Music]
oh boy you're good you clear all clear
and underwear I just took them off I'm
just going commando Yolo I don't care
yellow if I just don't [ __ ] again
because they'll be walking around naked
I feel so weird now it's fine
no good yeah yeah has this ever happened
this has never happened to me you've
never sharted no not as an adult you
have I definitely have when I was a boy
scout camp I did [ __ ] my pants at a
farting contest and they call me poop in
the pants boy weird weird dholtze dude
it's fine I can only breathe through one
nostril and you [ __ ] me up
damn Eric I cannot leave this room that
I poop my pants man that's it definitely
left this room well we got to do this
video and I've got a meeting at 1:30 so
let's let's barrel through it it's fun
wait can I just say one last thing no I
just wanna say like you're such a good
friend this is all just a prank
you're preying on the nice people here
I'm too nice yeah you didn't so I can
smell it guys okay don't you want to
hear I can smell the whole time I was
just worried about you man I was just
like yo he totally just shat in his
pants because there's no way you didn't
[ __ ] in your pants here's what it
smelled like
like something was like medically wrong
with you and now we know that you can
fart in front of Chris you can creep in
front of Chris my face and you just will
never say anything my best friend man
best best friends for life you could
show your pants around me anytime he got
me to admit that I ensured it as an
adult